Transcriber: Metin Akın
Gözden geçirme: Can Boysan
Bir gün gelecek
içindeki çocuğun, içindeki delinin
değerli olduğuna kanaat getireceksin.
O zaman korku ve endişe
yerini yaşam sevincine bırakacak.
O zaman zevk ve eğlence artık bir suç
olmaktan çıkıp bir lütuf olacak.
Benim tasarımım suç dediğim
noktada tam burada başlıyor.
Benden önce bu iki kelimeyi bir arada
kullanan insanları ele aldığımızda,
Hal Foster ve Adolf Loos karşımıza çıkıyor
Hal Foster, markalaşmayı
köleleşme olarak görmekte,
Adolf Loos Çağdaş mimarlığın
kapılarını açmakta
ve sadeleşmeye doğru
ilerlemeyi savunmaktadır.
Benim bakış açım,
insanın odağının
ölümden yaşama kayması ile ilgili.
Bizden önceki jenerasyon
elindekini göstermez
yaşadıkları mutluluğu paylaşmazken,
şu an yaşadığını,
yediğini, içtiğini, gezdiğini,
tozduğunu paylaşan
ve bundan alkış alan bir kitle karşımızda.
Dolayısıyla artık yaşamın odağı
ölümden yaşama kaymış durumda.
Bunu aslında biraz sığ bulan
bir üst jenerasyonla karşı karşıyayız.
Sanata da baktığımızda
aynı şeyi görmekteyiz.
19. yüzyıla kadar sanatta
Memento Mori, Omnia Vanitas gibi
ölüm ve yaşamında ölümün değerliliğini,
yaşamın değersizliliğini ön plana çıkaran
birtakım eserler görüyoruz.
Ama 19. yüzyıl, Endüstri Devrimiyle
ve Immanuel Kant -- tabii ki sanat
felsefesinin yapılmaya başlanmasıyla --
"Sanat sanat içindir,
sanat toplum içindir"
gibi felsefeler karşımıza çıkıyor.
Ve bu da aslında
sanatın demokratikleşmesini sağlıyor.
Tasarım ve aslında lüks
ayrıcalıklı bir kesime ait olmayı
bırakıp herkesin oluyor.
Herkesin seçtiğini, beğendiğini
alma hakkı sağlıyor.
Dolayısıyla endüstri devrimi
bize çok artılar kazandırmış olsa da
kendi çelişkileri ile birlikte geldi.
Bizi yalnızlaştırdı, monotonlaştırdı.
Sonuç olarak sanatta da
Mona Lisa’nın dingin gözlerinden
Edvard Munch'un içsel bir çığlık atan
scream tablosuna kadar geldik.
Peki, tasarım bunun neresinde?
Tasarım bu çelişkiyi çözmeye
yardımcı olabilir mi?
Evet olabilir.
Tasarım, mimarlık
xyz düzleminden çok daha fazladır.
İsterseniz dünyanın
en güzel tasarımını yapın,
en güzel mekanını tasarlayın.
Kötü kokarsa gidemezsiniz.
Demek ki mimarlık
xyz düzleminden daha fazladır.
Veya bizler yetmişlerde
bilimsel okuryazarlığa sahip olsaydık,
çiçek çocuklar gibi.
Onların akımlarını devam ettirebilseydik
bugün karşılaştığımız
küresel ısınma gibi problemleri
çok daha ucuza çözebilirdik.
Yani korkmamız gereken
aslında yapay zeka değil,
atom bombasının tuşuna basan kişilerdir.
Zaten insan kendinden çok daha bilge,
sonsuz bilgiye sahip olan
doğanın içinde yaşamaktadır.
Veya kendine çıkış bulmuştur,
bunun için de yaşamını sürdürmektedir.
Yapay zeka ile bağdaşması da
bunun sonucu olarak devam edecektir.
Peki, tasarım bunu değiştirmemizi
nasıl sağlayabilir?
Son zamanlarda hayatımızda
bu değişikliğe katkı sağlayabilecek
herhangi bir unsur var mı?
Var tabii.
Bunlardan bir tanesi sensörler.
Yani nöro, sinir bilimi.
Sinir bilimi bence önümüzdeki yüzyılın
oyun kurallarını değiştirici
en önemli bilimi olarak karşımızda duruyor
Bunun mimari ile birleştiği noktada
nöro mimarlık
yani sinir bilimi
ve mimarlığın birleşmesi.
Peki nedir nöro mimarlık?
Akıllı şehirlere geldik,
akıllı nesnelere geldik,
nesnelerin internetine geldik
Le Corbusier'in, "ev bir makinadır",
tanımından geçtik.
Ve aslında
Le Corbusier'in ev bir makinadır tanımı,
ev içinde yaşadığımız
bir makinedir tanımı,
tam da şu an kendini doğruluyor.
Akıllı şehirlerle birlikte ilerliyoruz.
Ama halbuki
makine bizle iletişime geçmiyor.
Bizim duygularımızı dikkate almıyor.
Kendi açma kapama duygusu var.
Ve belli frekansları, ayarları
bu doğrultuda hareket ediyor.
Beni çok da dikkate alarak
varlığını devam ettirmiyor.
Ama nöro bilim
yani aslında sinir bilimi
ve bunun mimarlıkla ilgili
bağlantılarına bakınca
önümüzdeki yüzyılda
şu ana kadar ön görmediğimiz
başka sektörler açılacak.
Şu an hayalini bile kuramadığımız
bir mimari ile karşı karşıya kalacağız.
Peki nedir bu mimari?
Yapay zekayı barındıran,
sensörler barındıran,
insan ile etkileşime geçen,
meteorolojiden, yapay zeka
vasıtasıyla bilgisini toplayıp
güneş enerjisini,
rüzgar enerjisini kullanan.
Artık şehirler tamamen
bir enerji vampiri gibi çalışmayacak.
Kendi kendine yeten
mekanizmalara dönecek.
Atık suyunu temizleyecek.
Çöpünü yakıt olarak kullanacak.
Belki daha ilerisinde
çok daha farklı şeyler olacak.
Bugün bile baktığımızda,
evinizin elektriğini,
kombisini, perdesini
siz yokken içinde
açıp kapamak istiyorsanız
aslında artık ev
makineleşmekten robotlaşmaya gitmektedir.
Mimaride peki tek önemli nokta bu muydu?
Başka ne gibi önemli noktalar vardı?
Bir de önemli noktamız
perspektifin bulunuşudur.
Peki perspektif ne yaptı?
Orda durup duran dünya ile
benim onu algılamam arasındaki
teknik bağlantıyı sağladı.
Bugün nöro mimarlık dediğimiz,
sinir bilimi ve mimarlığın birleşmesi de
orda durup duran ben ile
mimarlık arasındaki bağı sağlayacak.
Çünkü bugün mimarimiz incelendiğinde,
arkasında çöpten başka bir şey
bırakmadığını görüyoruz.
Halbuki doğa böyle değildir.
Enerjiyi enerjiye çevirir.
Arkada çöp bırakmaz, ses bırakmaz.
Uğultu yoktur.
Her sesin bir anlamı vardır.
Bugün şehirlerimizi kirli yapan
aslında en büyük unsur uğultudur.
Demek uğultu da mimarinin
bir faktörü olarak karşımızda.
Peki, bunları niye anlattım?
Çünkü insan teknolojileri el verdiğince
gelişimine devam edecek.
En olmadık yerlerde inşaat yapmış,
en olmadık şartlarda yaşamış
ve varlığını sürdürmüştür.
Alet ile ilişkisi çağların
en başından beri başlar
ve bu alete işlev yüklemeye
hep var olmuştur kendi içinde.
Dolayısıyla, bu teknolojik
imkanlarımız gittikçe
uzay mimarisine açılacağız.
Başka olmayan ülkelerde,
olmayan topraklarda,
yıldızlar arası belki,
bir gün gezegenler arası
inşaatlar yapacağız.
Ben demin size,
bu sunumumda aslında
bunun nasıl olacağının
anahtarlarını ve yol haritasını verdim.
Üst araştırmasını size bırakıyorum.
Teşekkürler.
(Alkış)